so ganz anderes thema sie sind
verzweifelt sie fühlen sich wirklich im
stich gelassen es geht um menschen die
nach der korona impfung schwer krank
wurden und symptome haben die sich
irgendwie nicht erklären lassen diagnose
postweg syndrom also dass nach impfung
syndrom kroner impfschäden und die
klagen die nehmen deutlich zu
felicia ist 29
eifrig tipp die schauspielerin auf dem
balkon ihrer frankfurter wohnung auf die
tastatur sie ist eine junge frau mitten
im leben eigentlich
ich habe mich letztes jahr am zweiten
mai entlassen und
felicia leidet am postweg syndrom auf
deutsch nach impfung syndrom die
symptome starke nervenschmerzen
kopfschmerzen neurologische ausfälle
muskelzucken lähmungserscheinungen
konzentrationsstörungen und felicia ist
mit ihrer erkrankung nicht allein mein
leben hat sich komplett verändert ich
bin mutter einer dreijährigen tochter
ich bin am manchen tag nicht in der lage
mich um mein kind zu kümmern mein mann
ist alleinverdiener ist das für uns auch
finanziell extrem
belastende situation mein umfeld hat
sich teilweise auch von mir abgewendet
beide jungen frauen wurden durch die
impfung gegen kobe 19 aus dem leben
gerissen es folgte ein wahrer ärzte
marathon die hausärzte waren überfordert
viele fachärzte nahmen dagegen die
symptome nicht ernst erst nach
monatelangen leidensweg und jeder menge
eigenen recherche im internet fanden sie
eine anlaufstelle in der uniklinik
marburg in der postbank ambulanz werden
solche krankheitsbilder genau untersucht
wichtig es geht hier nicht um kritik an
der impfung sondern an der fehlenden
nachsorge
müssen impfen wir müssen uns auch
zukünftig schützen es führt kein weg an
der impfung vorbei aber wir müssen uns
überlegen welches sind die
bevölkerungsgruppen die wir zukünftig
schützen müssen ob wir das gleiche
antigen bin ob wir zwischendurch
antikörper bestimmungen machen all das
sind fragen die sind nicht beantwortet
wir haben aber nur diesen sommer um
diese fragen zu klären
bis zu 2000 patienten stehen denn der
postweg ambulanz auf der warteliste in
vielen fällen hat die korona impfung
unterschwellig vorhandene krankheiten
angekurbelt und zu massiven
nebenwirkungen geführt so auch bei
tamara aus tübingen dass sie hier auf
die kamera zu laufen kann ist großes
glück neun monate war die 28 jährige ans
bett gefesselt konnte sich bestenfalls
mit rollator oder rollstuhl bewegen es
gab keinen alltag mehr also
bis zuletzt riss sich nach marokko ging
war ich bettlägerig das bedeutet ich bin
aufgewacht ich habe versucht den weg bis
zur toilette zu schaffen wenn danach
wieder ins bett ich hatte sehr starke
schmerzen
es ist gerade die hilflosigkeit die drei
frauen wütend macht arbeiten können sie
aktuell nicht stattdessen versuchen sie
selbst in internetforen und auf social
media über das postbank syndrom
aufzuklären schäden sind nicht mehr zu
machen die nervenschäden die
gefäßschäden das läuft einfach weiter in
dieser zeit wo ich wo andere betroffene
keine hilfe bekommen ich habe
tatsächlich einfach das vertrauen in die
medizin und auch in der politik in dem
fall verloren das vertrauen verloren in
die politik vor allem im gesundheits
minister karl lauterbach der erst
kürzlich in einem teaser-video das post
wachs in rom verharmlost das wird
untersucht das kann man nicht unter den
teppich kehren es ist aber nicht
vergleichbar mit der schwere der
erkrankung von cross trophy ich wünsche
mir ein gespräch mit karl lauterbach und
ich wünsche mir dass er auch dafür sorgt
dass es anlaufstellen gibt nicht erst in
einem halben jahr sondern an der gestern
am besten gestern oder doch zumindest
bevor gegen ende des jahres die nächste
booster welle los los
und wir begrüssen jetzt dr lisa federle
uns zugeschaltet pandemie beauftragte
des landkreises tübingen und auch
bundesverdienstkreuz trägerin schön dass
sie bei uns sind frau doktor federle
wir haben das schicksal der frauen jetzt
in unserem antrag eben gerade
geschildert sind es dramatische
einzelfälle oder ist es ein phänomen
diese impfschäden über das bisher noch
nicht genug gesprochen wurde das
vielleicht auch noch nicht genug
untersucht wurde
also ich glaube dass es nicht genug
untersucht da es bisher an ich habe auch
karl lauterbach ja vor im januar schon
darum gebeten dass es sich um die
datenbank wird
und ich glaube auch dass die leute nicht
genügend ernst genommen werden und es
gibt viel zu wenig anlaufstellen wir
haben den team hier eine
selbsthilfegruppe aber es gibt tausend
leute tausende von leuten mit fragen und
es sicher an den mails die ich bekommen
sie sich einfach hilflos fühlen und der
effekt ist der dadurch dass die dass die
natürlich auch ihre stimme am himmel
gibt es immer mehr leute die sagen sie
lassen sich nicht mehr hin
das wäre allerdings nicht die konsequenz
die man jetzt daraus ziehen sollte oder
dass man jetzt den menschen angst macht
und sagt nein sie sollten sich auf gar
keinen fall impfen lassen das ist jetzt
viel zu gefährlich
nein das ist absolut nicht die
konsequenz und das ist auch befehle ort
den ich den nicht der regierung bzw auch
darin gesundheitsminister an dass sie ja
wir müssen klare daten haben und dann
können wir wenn wir klare daten haben
die leute klar aufklären und ihnen sagen
das und das konkrete risiko haben sie
eins zu 100 oder so und so lange aber so
wie derzeit ständig irgendwelche studien
durch die gegend ballern die dann
widerrufen werden
die einen sagen es hat 50 mal mehr
risiken als bisher in den studien
angegeben das wird dann verteidiger
widerrufen das verunsichert die menschen
das muss noch aufzustehen und deswegen
muss man mal eine klare linie einkommen
welche versäumnisse werfen sie da ganz
konkret in gesundheitsminister vor der
hat erst gesagt es gibt keine
nebenwirkungen und dann wird so ein
bisschen schwammig jetzt sieht man diese
berichte und denkt sich natürlich ova
was ist denn jetzt los haben wir das
überhaupt richtig im griff dass genau
untersucht werde ich genau aufgeklärt es
bleibt der geschmack das passiert nicht
also ich glaube das problem ist dass man
da einfach ich habe ja wie gesagt mal
mit ihm telefoniert und habe dann gesagt
natürlich gibt es viele ärzte die das
gar nicht melden die nebenwirkungen aber
die kassen haben die daten man könnte
über die kassen die verschlüsselten
daten abfragt und dann versuchen das
auszuwerten und ich glaube dass das die
regierung oder das fahrweise des
ministerium auch so beschäftigt ist mit
anderen dingen dass er sagt meyer augen
zu und durch irgendwie haben wir das
schon hinkriegen und es kam ja auch
immer die these dass bis ende des
jahres das ganze sowieso mehr oder
weniger auch erledigt hat das ist aber
nicht so und deswegen glaube ich ist es
umso wichtiger um eben auch die leute
gut informieren zu können weil ich kann
von meinen patienten beispielsweise
nicht erwarten dass sich impfen lassen
wenn ich ihn nicht klare ansagen
hinlegen kann
zumindest bei der
sagt dr lisa federle vielen dank frau
federle fähre einschätzung zu diesem
thema dankeschön